house of the dragon game of thrones
prequel series that will air next year
is currently filming on multiple
locations and while filming is happening
we have more actors and more roles
revealed and therefore we have more
character explaining to do
house of the dragon although based on
georgia or martin's targaryen history
book fire and blood
will not feature targaryens only but
many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
while the cast for most of the main
characters was already announced
such as those for viserys saigon daemon
and rhaenyra targaryen
as well as for otto and alice and
hightower
and corliss valerian one of the most
important characters in the story has
recently been announced
by none other than georgia or martin
himself
martin announced the newest casting for
house of the dragon
and the role is for the king maker sir
kristen cole
who will be played by fabian frankel
martin gave the following description of
the character
cole plays a key role in the dance of
the dragons
as his nickname hints he is the common
born son of the steward
to the lord of blackhaven he's got no
claim to lands or titles
all he has is honor and his skill with
sword and lance
he is a challenger a champion cheered by
the comments beloved of the ladies
he is a lover or is he a seducer or is
he a betrayer
or is he a breaker of hearts and a maker
of kings
i can tell you that sir kristen cole is
one of those characters that you will
love and hate
which in my opinion is the best type of
character kristen is a complex character
he is one of the best knights of his
time lord commander of the kingsguard
and as the story progresses he even
becomes the hand of the king
at the beginning of our story his loyal
friend and protector of princess
rhaenyra
but later upon some mysterious events he
changes his allegiance to queen alicent
rhaenyra's enemy at king's landing court
and later serves king aegon
and fights against rhaenyra during the
entire civil war
the targaryen civil war is the key event
of the show
as it's the key in a history of house
targaryen the dance of the dragons
which divided westeros in two and
launched a huge war
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
round it made house targaryen much
weaker
especially because this conflict
resulted with the extinction of their
dragons
while its numbers were at its peak at
the war start
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
back to sir kristen cole and his
importance in all of this
sir kristin cole was a knight from house
call
made a member of king viserys the first
targaryen skins guard
eventually rising to lord commander
christian convinced viserys's son aegon
to claim the rule of the seven kingdoms
as his father lay dead
this led to the dance of the dragons a
civil war between aegon ii
and his elder sister rhaenyra whom
miseries had long trained as his
successor
for this he became known as kristen the
king maker
he was an exceptionally skilled warrior
especially with his morning star
kristen appears in the history of house
targaryen by winning a melee
an attorney at maidenpool to celebrate
the ascension of viserys the first
targaryen
drawing attention of the royal court by
knocking dark's sister from the hands of
prince daemon targaryen with his morning
star
he gave the victor's laurel to
seven-year-old princess rhaenyra
targaryen
whose favor he wore while on horsing
daemon in the joust
as well as famed cordial twins of the
kingsguard
before being unhorsed by lordly man
malister
thereafter king viserys indulged rynera
by naming kristen her personal
thorn shield in 105 ac the 23 year old
kristen became a member of the
kingsguard
taking the place of the legendary sir
rime redwine
cole wore rhaenyra's favorite in a
tournament in 111ac
where he unhorsed sergey in hightower
younger brother and champion to king
viserys's second wife and queen
alice and hightower in 112 ac
sir kristen was still reiner's champion
and constant companion
lord commander sir harold westerling
died in that year
and kristen was named his successor to
lead the white cloaks
it was rumored that cole had an affair
with rhaenyra in 113 ac
septon eustace says that sir kristen
slipped into rhaenyra's bedchamber to
confess his love
offering to escape the kingsguard life
with her to one of the free cities where
he would pledge his sword
to some merchant prince jesus also says
that ryanair refused him
saying a targaryen was meant to be more
than a wife of a sellsword
and that if he could forget his king's
guard mouse
he could forget marriage mouse the royal
full mushroom
tells a different tale that rhaenyra had
been exercising her enticements with her
uncle
prince daemon so that she would lose her
maidenhead
to kristen a man she loved rather than
her betrothed cousin
leonard valerian she failed to seduce
sir kristen in white sword tower however
and the spurned princess took solace in
sir harvin break bone strong
this is why even if you read the book
fire and blood on which this prequel is
based
you still will not know how most of the
stories play out
because the book is not the actual
history but the history that the author
wrote using many different statements
while the author does offer few possible
scenarios
it doesn't mean any of them are true
because none of them were in the room
with rhaenyra and kristen
it's just what they were told that
happened whatever the way of it
cole went from being her most loyal
defender
to her bitterest foe and rhaenyra soon
left for driftmark with brake bones
as her new sworn shield in 114 ac
sir kristen as the king's guard to king
viserys
attended the wedding of rhaenyra to
lenore which included seven days of
feasting and jousting
cole fought with queen ellison's token
and during a melee left break bones with
a broken collar bone and shattered elbow
thereafter prompting mushroom to call
him break bones
kristen's morning star also cracked the
helm of the knight of kisses
laenor's favorite sir joffrey lonemouth
who died from six days later
well many were angered at christian for
this including king viserys
queen ellis scent did not share their
displeasure
and asked that he be made her personal
sore shield
koldas became a stone supporter of queen
elisande
kristen tutored ellison's fear son
prince aemond targaryen to be a skilled
swordsman
despite a man having only one eye left
after rhaenyra's son
wounded him in a fight due to
contradictory sources
kristen's motives in supporting aegon ii
are unclear
some say that he acted from ambition as
zagon was more controllable than his
willful half sister rhaenyra
indeed aegon ii eventually raised
kristin to the office of hand of the
king however some say rhaenyra rejected
him
adding a personal dimension to the
conflict
others allow call nobler motives and
claim he was defending ancient
andal custom giving precedence to sons
of her daughters
or that he did not wish to see
rhaenyra's children who he believed to
be
children born out of wedlock to inherit
the iron tround
in any event many of the lords of the
realm were aware of viserys's wish
to have rhaenyra succeed him as house
targaryen's first ruling queen
and stood behind the princess after king
viserys died
most notable of which were corliss
valerian and craig and stark
again due to contradictory sources
during the meeting of viserys's small
council
after king viserys's death in 129 ac
cole is noted to have either slitted
throughout or thrown from a window
the aged lord lyman beesbury the only
member of the council to support
crowning princess rhaenyra instead of
prince aegon
the rest of the council were allies of
cerrado and queen ellis and hightower
kristen later crowned egg on the second
with the iron and ruby crown of fake on
the conqueror
however rhaenyra who was at dragonstone
at the time of her father's death and
aegon's coronation
refused to support aegon beginning the
great armed conflict which engulfed the
seven kingdoms and became known as the
dance of the dragons
as rhaenyra's supporters gathered their
forces
aegon the second became frustrated with
his grandfather and hand
seroto hightower and awarded the office
to kristen cole
the king maker's forces quickly took
dusk and dale and rook's rest
the latter after a fierce battle and
prince eamon
targaryen became the protector of the
realm and prince regent because of
aegon's injuries in the battle
kristen remained ahead eamond and the
kingmaker led an army of 4 thousand
greens from king's landing to retake
herron hall in the riverlands
from prince daemon targaryen who
abandoned the castle before kristen
arrived
and took this opportunity to take king's
landing
after hearing that craig and stark's
winter wolves defeated his biggest
allies
the lannister in the battle by the
lakeshore eamon began burning the
riverlands
and coal marched his remaining 3600
grains
south along the western shore of the
god's eye intending to join with the
army of lord ormund hightower
however the king maker's forces were
ambushed by the winter wolves and river
knights
south of the god's eye christian's
forces were outnumbered
due to one by the forces of the
riverlands and the north
kristen held a parley with the winter
wolves commander lord rodrick dustin
sir pate of longleaf and sergar bald
grey
kristen offered to surrender but was
refused by three blacks
upon this refusal sir kristen a famed
knight who was also the lord commander
of the kingsguard for aegon ii
in addition to being the king's hand
prepare to fight all three of his
counterparts at once
before he could do so however the king
maker was struck down by arrows fired by
red robbed rivers and two of his
longbowmen
with kristin dead lord dustin sounded
the charge of winter wolves and the
river knights into kristen's now
leaderless army which quickly collapsed
perhaps we could end kristen's story
with this quote about him by jaime
lannister
meloris tyrell told him that the best
kingsguard heroes will always be
remembered
jaime replied with the best and worst
and a few who were a bit of both
like chris nicole was chris then in love
with rhaenyra who became her worst enemy
after she refused him
or did he refuse her and sided with
aegon
was skull an honorable knight or
ambitious man with no morals
and was he truly the best warrior of his
time even better than daemon himself
all of that and more we'll see in the
upcoming game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon
which airs next year on hbo thank you so
much for watching and i hope to see you
in the next one